Well, good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Mike Caligiuri. I'm past president of AACR and now
proud to serve as the treasurer of AACR.
It's my great pleasure and honor to introduce Dr.
Lillian L. Siu, the 2025-26
AACR president.
Over the past year, Dr. Siu has served
the AACR and the entire cancer research community with great
distinction.
We're extremely grateful for her steadfast leadership of
AACR and for her unrelenting efforts to advance our
mission to prevent, intercept, and cure all types of
cancer. During her term as president, Dr.
Siu led AACR to promote innovation and progress in areas of
scientific priority, to advocate for robust federal funding for
basic, translational, and clinical research, and to
strengthen AACR's collaborative relationships with the global cancer
research community.
Dr. Siu has been a proud AACR member since
1996, and she has served the organization in a
number of leadership roles. Most notably, she was a
member of the Board of Directors from 2017 to
2020, and she served on the AACR Finance and
Audit Committee since 2019.
She has also made critical contributions to understanding and enhancing
AACR's annual meeting's role as the touchstone
event for the entire cancer research community.
She served as a member of the Annual Meeting Program Committee in
2014, as Program Committee co-chair in
2012 and 2016, and most notably as the
program chair, along with Dr. Matthew Vander Heiden, for the
AACR Annual Meeting in 2025. She
also served on the Annual Meeting Clinical Trials Committee from
2012 to 2016, and she chaired this
committee in both 2016 and 2017.
She has also provided vital leadership to AACR's scientific publishing
initiatives. Her contributions include chairing the steering committee for
the AACR Cancer Progress Report 2025 and
serving as a member of the Publications Committee since 2016.
And again, most notably, since 2021, she has
served as the founding editor-in-chief of "Cancer Research
Communications," AACR's open access journal.
Dr. Siu received her medical degree from the University of Toronto in
1991, completed her training in internal medicine at the Royal
College of Physicians and Surgeons of Canada in 1995, and
received her certification in medical oncology from the Royal
College in 1996. She completed a Canadian
Association of Medical Oncology fellowship in
oncopharmacology at the Princess Margaret Cancer Center in
1997, and after completing a clinical research
fellowship in new drug development at UT San Antonio,
she returned to Princess Margaret in 1998 to establish the Phase 1
Clinical Trials Program there. At the Princess
Margaret University Health Network in Toronto, Canada, Dr.
Siu serves as a senior medical oncologist, director of the Phase 1
Clinical Trials Program, co-director of
the Robert and Maggie Bras and Family Drug Development
Program, clinical lead for Tumor Immunotherapy Program,
and BMO Chair in Precision Cancer Genetics.
She also holds a faculty appointment as professor of medicine at the University of
Toronto.
Throughout her career, Dr. Siu has made crucial contributions
to anticancer drug development and translational and
clinical research. Her innovative research, which is dedicated to
optimizing clinical trial design and execution, has resulted in the
accelerated discovery and development of novel
immunotherapeutics and molecularly targeted therapeutics for
cancer, head and neck patients, as well as gastrointestinal
malignancies.
Dr. Siu has been recognized with many honors and many awards, including the
European Society for Medical Oncology Targeted Anticancer
Therapy Honorary Award in 2020, the American
Society of Clinical Oncology International Woman Who Conquered Cancer
Mentorship Award in 2020, and the Eaton Research
Scholar Researcher of the Year from the University of Toronto Department of
Medicine in 2016, and many others.
She's also an elected fellow of the Canadian Academy of Health
Sciences and of the American Society of Clinical Oncology, and
in 2024, she was elected as a fellow of the
AACR Academy. Her presidential address is entitled
"Mapping the Molecular Landscape of Head and Neck Cancer to Inform
Pan-Tumor Targeting." Please join me in welcoming our
esteemed AACR president, Lillian L.
Siu, to the stage. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
30 years in the making.
First of all, let me thank you for coming to this
session at 5:30 in the evening
on Sunday. I'm sure you had a lot of plans for tonight,
but
I don't mind if you leave a bit early to go to do your dancing.
But thank you for coming. It has been a great honor for me to serve as
your president of the AACR, and as of
24 hours from now, I will be passing my baton to Dr.
Keith Flaherty, who will become the president of AACR tomorrow.
So it's very humbling for me. I have learned a lot this year, and I want to
thank the membership and all the support that you have given me as the
president. So I've decided to highlight some work that I have done,
together with my team at Princess Margaret, in terms of
research in head and neck cancer and how it informs us to
understandPan-tumor targeting.
So how we can learn from one disease to go beyond that to other
tumors that affect our patients.
These are my financial disclosures.
So as I mentioned, I am a medical oncologist who focuses on head neck
cancer research, but I also do phase one
clinical trials. In this talk, I'm going to cover early disease,
focusing specifically in the area of molecular residual disease or
minimal residual disease, or MRD.
How we can leverage this opportunity to
intercept intervene cancer so that we can eradicate cancer at
a much earlier stage and hopefully cure more patients.
I will also touch on advanced disease in the head neck cancer setting,
looking at some of the biomarker research we have done, and really
understanding, again, how we can leverage this to inform other
diseases that affect the human body.
So first of all, MRD, I think this term is now becoming more and
more common in the medical literature because we are
starting to be more confident that we can detect
minute quantities of cancer in the form of circulating tumor
DNA or other circulating biomarkers in the blood.
And now we also have the technology that
is ultrasensitive, as I mentioned, with ctDNA,
and that allow us to actually understand the molecular burden of
cancer that we previously could not measure because we only could
see disease on CT scans or MRI scans or
protein biomarkers such as tumor biomarkers.
And this is obviously a phenomenon that makes sense because our
hematological colleagues have been following patients with
MRD and able to eradicate cancer in that
situation. For example, the best example being multiple
myeloma, where MRD is actually an approved endpoint.
And then obviously it will allow us to have an
opportunity to test a lot of new drugs much earlier on
to really eradicate, again, cancers and also test the
efficacy of these drugs and also long-term safety.
As a drug developer, I develop most of my drugs in the advanced disease setting
when patients have already exhausted standard treatments and have very
resistant cancer. So the opportunity to give these drugs much
earlier to be able to eradicate it in a much higher
proportion of patients is extremely attractive.
So in head neck cancer, we work in a team, and many of my
team are in the audience, so I will obviously thank them for all
the support and effort they have provided to make the various
projects we are showcasing in this meeting
actually
possible. So the first project we did is a study called
PREMERIDIAN. It's PREMERIDIAN because we wanted to do a project
called Meridian, which is an MRD project in head neck.
But given that the data in this field is limited,
we thought it is better to start with a feasibility study.
And I would say that this is probably a good way to think about looking at
MRD in other diseases. To really think about the feasibility, because
to measure MRD, there are many moving parts.
You will need support, for example, from your surgical colleagues, from
your radiation oncology colleagues, because these are patients undergoing
curative treatment. Could be surgery followed by adjuvant radiation or
adjuvant chemoradiation, or they could be undergoing concurrent
chemoradiation as a curative treatment option.
We want to measure their circulating tumor DNA before their
treatment and then afterwards,
in several time points, in order to see whether there is residual
disease in the blood. And as a result of this, and
Ricky Sands, who is in the audience, and the team really came up with this
feasibility project called PREMERIDIAN.
Also in collaboration with Scott Breitman, who I understand also is in the
audience,
who really has been providing a lot of scientific expertise in
terms of various ctDNA assays. We also
collaborated with commercial vendors.
We worked with a company, Neogenomics, with their tumor-informed assay.
Tumor-informed meaning we had to sequence a tumor, understand what's in the tumor,
and then use that information to track specific
variants in the plasma so that we know, in a personalized
way, which cancer variant, tumor variants are present in the blood
in order for us to be more sensitive to detect these
microscopic traces of DNA in the blood.
But in addition, we had other assays.
For example, we used a tumor-agnostic assay,
a panel of recurrent alterations very
commonly present in head neck cancer, again in collaboration with
Scott Breitman in using the CAP-Seq, which is a hybrid capture assay,
to again look at very specific panel of genes that we think are
going to be detectable in patients with head neck cancer.
But obviously it's a bit of a guess because you do not know that tumor
will have those variants present.
And given that head neck cancer is a HPV, human
papillomavirus-driven disease, we obviously also
captured HPV DNA in the blood as well.
So this is a feasibility study. We did this project actually
during COVID, so it was challenging.
But we were able to capture,
in about 17 patients or so, almost 100% of the blood
samples available. So
obviously, I don't have time to go through the entire study in detail, but using
the radar assay, as I mentioned, we had found in two
patients with a lead time of between 100 and
245 days that had positive
molecular residual disease present in the blood in terms of positive
ctDNA assay preceding their clinical diagnosis
of recurrence. And that's an important point, again, to inform other
tumor types, that just because a ctDNA is positive, it
doesn't mean they have molecular residual disease.
You do have to do a clinical as well as radiological survey to
make sure there is no macroscopic disease present, because if they are present,
they're no longer having molecular residual disease.
But you will see thatIn these four or five
patients that subsequently relapsed
almost
one or two years out, some of them even further out,
we were not able to detect using that assay, despite it being
very sensitive. So clearly, a lot of factors can affect
the presence of MRD. Your level of sensitivity, your limit of
detection is obviously important.
The tumor fraction, the proportion of tumor that is present in the
plasma is also very important, and different tumors will have
different characteristics based on their
biologies.
So the bottom line from that PRE-MERIDIAN study is, number one, it was feasible.
We were able to pull it off in the middle of a pandemic, which obviously
was challenging but was very gratifying to
us that we were able to do that. And in this
particular study, in the four assays we did, the RADAR assay did
quite well. As you can see, it was able to segregate out the
patients who did not do well and the patients that had a much better
relapse-free survival because their MRD assay was negative.
And using a highly sensitive HPV sequencing
assay, we were able to also identify early relapse or
predict earlier relapse than those who were MRD
negative.
So I'm going to highlight some of the work that we're actually presenting in this
meeting. This is
going to be presented by Dr. Sands in the "Clinical Trials Mini
Symposium" tomorrow in the afternoon.
I urge you to go to his session and listen to him, and then
hopefully you will hear a lot more than I'm going to just highlight today
in brief. So of course, as I mentioned, after the
feasibility study, we proceeded to do the MERIDIAN study, which is
really what we wanted to do. We wanted to look at MRD interception
in patients with locally advanced head neck
cancer, those who are undergoing definitive treatment.
And this is the schema of MERIDIAN.
So patients are going through definitive treatment, as I mentioned,
surgery followed by radiation or chemoradiation or definitive
chemoradiation. We track the baseline sample.
We obviously have CT scans as well.
If they were undergoing surgery, we also took an extra sample, and then if they are
going through radiation or chemoradiation, we have two time points,
mainly because we didn't really know what was the correct time point, which is the
best time point. So we wanted to collect one that is fairly early on at four
to six weeks after the treatment is finished.
And we wanted to also collect one at around eight to 12 weeks.
And if that one is in the follow-up point time two is equivocal,
we would draw another one at week 14 to
16 as follow-up time point three. If they're MRD
positive in this particular study, we again stayed on
with the NeoGenomics assay as well as the HPV sequencing,
and we would randomize them to a
bispecific. This is a study in collaboration with AstraZeneca,
where we had access to the PD-1
T-digit bispecific revagostamic, which is undergoing
investigational trials in lung cancer as well as other cancers.
Patients were randomized to that or in
observation, and the ratio was
meant to be three to one, so three to active drug versus one to
observation. Which is the standard of care because we normally would not be testing
these patients with any further drugs because we wouldn't know that they have MRD.
And then the primary endpoint for this study would be clearance of their
ctDNA in part D, which is the follow-up time point at week
two and week 10 post-completion of their treatment.
And those who are MRD negative by the assay, we would continue to follow them and
see how they fare. So that was our original plan
with a goal to enroll 200 patients.
We did not do that because I'll tell you later in the story, we
finished at around 50 patients, of which I'll give you some results, some hint of
the results. The patients that we included in the MERIDIAN assay, just in a
very brief summary, are patients with head neck cancer.
The key primary sites, which are oral cavity, oropharynx,
larynx, hypopharynx, and known primary, and patients that
are high risk HPV positive, or in general, most
HPV negative patients are high risk, so stage three and stage four
HPV negative patients undergoing curative treatment,
and they should have no contraindication for immunotherapy and have good organ
functions because they could be randomized to receive the bispecific.
And the interception part for them to enter
that part, they have to have a positive ctDNA result
because we need MRD patients at either follow-up point two
or follow-up point three if it's needed to confirm that if
follow-up point two was equivocal.
They have to have PD-L1 expression because they're going on to an
immunotherapy, and as I mentioned, to have no evidence of
macroscopic recurrence or disease.
So the assay that we needed real-time return was the point
that we needed to determine MRD, so the part B follow-up time
point, and then we also wanted the treatment time point to be
real-time return. All the other time points for both assays
were banked for later analyses. So obviously, we will
be presenting on the RADAR results during this meeting.
The HPV assay will be presented at a later time point.
As I mentioned, we wanted to enroll 200 patients, and we were ambitious.
We were able to enroll the first 50 patients, and we
decided to take a look at that point.
Out of the 50 or so patients, about 42 were evaluable at
time point two, and out of that, five of them had
positive ctDNA. But as you can seeOut of those
patients, many of them actually have macroscopic disease at
the time of us finding the positive ctDNA.
So at the end, we're only able to enroll two patients, one
randomized to active treatment and one did not.
And we'll tell you later on that one patient who
received the active treatment with the bispecific is free of recurrence
for over 22 months, and the person that was randomized to
observation, unfortunately, had disease progression.
There was a couple of patients with equivocal ctDNA at
follow-up point two, so we had to do the follow-up point three,
and one was positive and one was negative.
The positive patient was moved into that MRD positive
arm. In those who are negative for ctDNA so far, out of
the 35 patients, 30 are alive without recurrence, one
is alive with recurrence, one is diseased with recurrence,
and one is diseased without recurrence.
So at the end of part B, which is our
MRD window, about six patients were
ctDNA positive, but as I mentioned, some of them did have
positive clinical recurrence at that time.
So another take-home point is that MRD is not MRD
unless you really confirm that they do not have clinical radiological
recurrence. So this is the patient that was randomized to active treatment.
He was
treated with rivogostumab, and he has now been disease-free for
22 months.
And these are the Kaplan-Meier curves.
What we have learned that as you use more follow-up time
points instead of just landmark time points, or as you follow them
in any follow-up time points, the sensitivity increases.
And I think that's fairly true for most cancers, that a surveillance
strategy would give you more chance of
catching the MRD than to have very specific time points,
so-called landmark testing.
And again, I urge you to go to Dr. Sand's presentation
tomorrow where he'll present everything in a much greater
detail. But as expected, those who are MRD positive have
a much poorer relapse-free survival, and those who are MRD negative
had a much better relapse-free survival with a hazard ratio that
is significant.
So you will ask, so what's going on in the literature in that area?
So I've summarized the current literature to date with the orange
part being assays that are tumor-informed, as I
mentioned, that you needed to sequence a tumor and then subsequently
look into the plasma, and the bottom part being tumor agnostic, which
you do not need to have access to the tumor.
You use the assay
on the plasma by itself. So in
cases like these cases, these presentations, or these publications, you
can see that the tumor-informed assays generally have a higher
baseline detection, which is not surprising because you know what you're looking
for and you have a more sensitive assay.
And the tumor-agnostic assays tend to have a slightly
lower baseline detection.
You can also see in the parts where you have serial
collection has a better sensitivity and limit of detection,
or better sensitivity versus a single time point where the
sensitivity is by and large lower.
All of them have a lead time of approximately 4 to 10 months, and
when they're able to detect a ctDNA in the plasma, the hazard
ratio for relapse or survival is much worse than those who are MRD
negative. So that's the current literature.
This field is definitely evolving, and I think you should
definitely keep an eye on this space, and certainly, I think our
take-home from Meridian is that we need to find an assay that is
continuing to be more sensitive to be able to detect very,
very low quantities of ctDNA, and that longitudinal
tracking may further expand your interception
opportunities. I think HPV testing is also another
opportunity for MRD detection in this viral-driven cancer, and it
will definitely complement mutation-based testing in those who are
having HPV-positive oropharyngeal cancers.
So what are we doing in Meridian? We have amended the protocol.
We have adopted a newer assay, a more
ultrasensitive assay, and we have just reopened
for the next 50 patients to see whether by having
a different assay, we can have a higher chance of
detecting MRD. Because clearly, we have seen the hint
that that one patient we're able to randomize to the active
treatment, we are able to intercept this disease.
So I think if we're able to catch more of these cancers, we
are possibly able to change the outcome of these patients.
Just some words about MRD and cancer interception.
Perhaps the poster child for this
strategy is in bladder cancer. As many of you are aware of IMvigor
11 that was published in "The New England Journal of Medicine" by Tom Powles
last year, where patients who have
post-surgery for their bladder cancer, who have MRD
positive by ctDNA and receive immunotherapy did
much better in terms of PFS and OS,
DFS and OS than those who are MRD negative
with negative ctDNA. So there is definitely proof of concept out there
with certain diseases, but clearly one size cannot fit all.
We cannot say it works for every cancer, and the
challenges of different cancers are different.
Colon cancer perhaps is a bit easier, for example, to detect MRD than
head and neck cancer than some of the other cancers.
So the context is really important for
pan-tumor targeting.
So a few words about what we're doing in our institution about MRD.
We were very fortunate in the last several months receive a
donation from a philanthropist, Mr.
Peter Gillgan, who donated 50 millions to us for
understanding early cancer detection.
Thanks for clapping, Eddie .And we
are excited and we show them our vision that we
wanted to catch cancers early. We spend a lot of our energy on
advanced cancers, and it's important to do that, but it's even
more important to catch these cancers early.
So we explained the whole concept to Mr.
Gilgan, and he think this is a good way to invest his donation.
So we decided to create hopefully the world's largest MRD cohort,
and this is a pan-cancer cohort. Our goal is ambitious.
We wanted to enroll 7,000 patients over four years.
We put our first patient in on March 31st, and
this is for all cancers. We're actively working on
getting engagement from all our disease sites.
I think if
anything is successful, engagement of the multidisciplinary groups in our
institution is going to be one of the most important
first endpoints. We'll be collecting serial time points, as I
mentioned. I think single time point is probably not as good as serial time points.
And we're going to learn a lot in terms of multimodal testing,
not just ctDNA, but also radiomics, machine learning, et cetera.
And we're actively also planning interception.
Not just escalation when they're MRD positive, but also de-escalation if
they're MRD negative. So we have actually planned a whole journey
for these patients. We've created the infrastructure to do this with
nurse navigators. Patients are going to receive electronic
consenting. They will really understand what
MRD means, and we will track them both MRD negative and
positive.
And as I mentioned, we are actively planning
interception study to prove the utility of MRD interception,
because it's important, obviously, to escalate if they're positive, but if they're
negative, maybe we can think about opportunities to give them less toxic treatment
or shorter treatments so that they don't have to actually go through
toxic treatments without compromising cure.
So that's an important consideration for pan-cancer,
pan-tumor MRD interception.
I'm going to switch gear now to advanced cancers, just to
give a first story where we have, many years ago,
created a platform study called INSPIRE.
The name is really trying to inspire our
surgeons, our scientists, as well as
oncologists to work together on immunotherapy.
So we put 100 patients on immunotherapy with pembrolizumab,
and we collected all kinds of samples from these patients, tumor,
blood, et cetera. And over the course of two years,
2016 and 2018, we collected close to 200
biopsies and over 2,500 blood samples.
This study has been well-published, and you can see we have
many, many papers. But I think the biggest reward of this
study is, number one, we built a team that is
extremely interactive. We meet regularly with these
kinds of projects now. There's engagement, there's interest from clinicians
to hear about the scientists' work and vice versa.
And I want to point out in red, these are young investigators in our
institution. They are the first authors of these papers, many of which are high
impact journals with high
impact factors and readership. We wanted to promote our young
investigators to be in charge and to lead, and I think this is a
great way to do so. So we
have many readouts from INSPIRE, which I do not have time to really highlight.
One of the thing that we did is we did do a tumor-informed assay using the
biomarker collection for the ctDNA and actually
helped with the ctDNA monitoring for immunotherapy with the
Signatera assay. So you will see that it was
referenced in the Signatera in terms of the INSPIRE
study.
I'm going to highlight some work that we did again with Enrique, who is in the
audience. We were also curious about
if you collect
very frequent blood samples in patients with advanced cancers on
immunotherapy, when is the time that is the most sensitive
time point? So again, we collected many, many time points,
literally eight time points after the first dose of immunotherapy.
This was all PD-1 antibody-treated patients,
either
pembrolizumab or nivolumab. And the times were at day
zero, day two, day three, day eight, day 15, 22,
and 29. You can see that it's a very intensive
schedule. Again, it was a tough study to do because, again, it was
during the pandemic, but we were able to collect a lot of the samples.
And just to give you very high-level results of this published study in
"Clinical Cancer Research,"
very interestingly, in the patients that have responses in
terms of CR and PR and prolonged stable disease, as
expected, their ctDNA kinetics were
down-sloping, whereas those who have disease progression, their
ctDNA kinetics were kinetic. The time point that
seems to be the most sensitive is around day eight, that you can collect
and see that changes as early as day eight, in terms of day eight
to day 15 seems to be as good a time point
as a later time point. I know currently in clinical
trials, a lot of us collect ctDNA to look at the kinetics,
and most of us collect at, say, cycle one, day one, and then cycle two, day one,
just for convenience. But it's possible, I think, if you collect an earlier time
point, you may also have a very robust change that
you can use it to guide in terms of longer-term outcome.
This was a small study. It was only 15 evaluable patients.
But if you look at the drop in ctDNA at day eight versus
later time points or the rise compared to later time points, it can
again segregate patients into two fairly distinct groups in
terms of prognosis. And that's fairly consistent data in
terms of ctDNA changes in
correlation with longer-term outcomes across cancers.
Now, whether the day eight or day 15 time point applies to pan cancer
outside of the
head neck context, that's obviously, again, something to be further
tested.We also looked at peripheral
TCR, T-cell receptor repertoire in these patients.
In the top, these are the patients who have a decrease in ctDNA,
and in the bottom, these are the patients who have a rise in their
ctDNA. And interestingly, if you look at the TCR
repertoire, both in terms of richness and diversity, you can also
see two different groups of patients, those who have
a much more diversified and rich
TCR repertoire if their ctDNA kinetics are showing a downward
trend versus those who are having an upward trend where the
TCR repertoire and richness were much, much lower.
So that's a summation of that data.
Those who are having a drop in the ctDNA in the darker brown circles,
having the richness and diversity improving, versus those who are
having an increase in their ctDNA,
their repertoire would have much worse in terms of richness and
diversity. In the last few minutes, I just want to
highlight another piece of work that are also being presented by a
young investigator, Gregoire Marret, who is here, again, in the
audience, who's presenting a poster
tomorrow, is a late-breaking poster in poster board
nine, section 52, somewhere there.
I hope you come and visit him. He will want to hear from you in terms of your
questions. This is work that Gregoire has been working with us for the
past two years in collaboration with the University of
Calgary, with Dr. Pinaki Bose, who I think may be also in the
audience.
So we decided that we're interested to use the INSPIRE study, which
I mentioned to you earlier. One of the cohort in INSPIRE is
head-neck cancer. And in addition, we also
collaborated or collated the data from the IOCIN
study, the one I just mentioned, with very dense collection of
ctDNA. We assembled both cohorts to look
at patients who are immune checkpoint-naive, recurrent
metastatic head-neck cancer to look at really deep
dive into their spatial transcriptomics to understand
really what's happening in terms of the tumor microenvironment
at a cellular level. So we were fortunate to have 19
pre-treatment samples, seven on-treatment, and two post-treatment
samples, and we did analyses using the
Visium analyses. Again, I'm not going to give you too much detail because
I want you to go to Gregoire's poster, so therefore, I'll just give you some
very high-level summaries. We
did the usual unsupervised clustering, and we
obviously looked at the malignant spots and
non-malignant spots. We're able to find five clusters in the
malignant spots, and as you can see, the different groups in there.
And this is really recapitulating some of the work that Dr.
Bose from Calgary did because he was able to use,
again, spatial transcriptomics to look at early
head-neck cancer in the oral cavity, where he was identifying
both tumor core as well as leading edge, and they have completely
different spatial transcriptomic profile.
Interestingly, when Gregoire Marret look at
the copy number variation profile in these
five clusters, you can see they are actually quite similar, which would
suggest that interestingly, the intra-tumoral heterogeneity perhaps
is driven by the TME phenotypic plasticity as
opposed to CNV-driven clonal diversity.
And I think that's an area that's definitely worth thinking about in
terms of how much the TME is actually relevant to drive
intra-tumoral heterogeneity in head-neck cancer.
Dr. Marret is a PhD in bioinformatics, so he did a lot of
complicated bioinformatics work.
He literally looked at thousands, maybe tens and
thousands of dots in terms of spots that are close to the
malignant cells and really look at the neighborhood analyses
between the tumor cell edge as well as the neighboring
cells in the tumor microenvironment.
And using unsupervised clustering, he was able to find a
signature that splits into a inflamed
signature versus one that is really immune-suppressed signature
that dichotomize this group of patients, which is only
18. You're going to say, "Well, it's a very small number." But remember, this is
spatial transcriptomic. This is not bulk RNA.
This is really looking at cell by cell inside
under the microscope. And it split this group into
two different prognostic groups.
And the question I had asked Gregoire is, "So what?
Are we going to ever get this kind of data across different tumor
types to this kind of level?" We need to see if it actually is applicable,
number one, to bulk transcriptomics and number two, applicable to other
cancer types. So we did look at it as
applied to bulk transcriptomics across pan-cancers.
And you can see, obviously, not all studies are on the same
direction, but at the end, the bottom line in terms of the
overall summation is that there is a hint that this is an
interesting predictive signature in terms of response to
immunotherapy that is able to translate to bulk
transcriptomics and in a pan-cancer context, to split
out the group that is more sensitive to immune checkpoint blockade versus the
one that is less so.
So learning that, we have decided to create a new
study, again, in advanced head-neck cancer in collaboration with
GlaxoSmithKline to look at patients receiving
a antibody drug conjugate targeting B7H3, a
very promising checkpoint, and then also in
combination with anti-PD-1 therapy in two different cohorts.
And we're going to do similar to what we did in INSPIRE, very deep
dive. We're going to look at TCR. We're going to look at spatial
transcriptomics to see whether we can, againNot
only recapitulate the signature that we have examined,
but also to find other biomarkers using also
patient-derived models that we will get from tumor specimens from these
patients. So this is really trying to learn from what we have learned
from the previous study to expand our scope
to look at other areas of head and neck cancer, especially focusing on the
tumor microenvironment, which we think is really, really key in head and neck
cancer to drive response to immunotherapy.
I'm on my second last slide just to show that
together with Gregoire and another promising fellow,
Mercedes Herrera, who is from Spain, we wrote a
perspective a few months ago on really thinking about
how the whole field of clinical trial design should go.
And this is a perspective in "Cancer Cell"
where we think that the current
clinical trial design, not just head and neck cancer, is too static.
We write the protocol, we try and execute the protocol
with what we have written. It's really not adaptive, not dynamic.
And we think that the future should go where we should continuing to use data
from extrinsic sources, such as all the public information
out there related to the target and the patient.
And we should really learn from each patient that goes into trial in terms of
the drug-target-patient matching, and iteratively
learn to match the patient to the best drug that is available,
provided that we can get all our pharmaceutical partners to
collaborate and contribute their best medicines for us to
test the same strategy. And I think this kind of
adaptive learning, especially using AI that really is
very much
right in the front center of our knowledge field right now, is going to help us
design clinical trials in a much more informative and
smarter way.
I'm going to conclude by saying I think head and neck cancer is just a discovering
engine for other cancers. We have been able to use it to learn a
lot in terms of immune resistance and biomarkers.
I think the dynamic biomarkers are going to be very important in terms
of tracking the various biomarkers such as ctDNA,
TCR repertoire, and others. I think the spatial context is
obviously important and may be pan-tumor relevant, and
it may allow us to actually extrapolate to other cancers.
And we're interested in interception because we think that this is the group of
patients we can make a much bigger difference than in the advanced care setting.
Just to thank a lot of people, I'm sure I'm going to miss some, hopefully
not a lot. I want to thank all the programs that have been supporting this
work, all our funders in terms of providing us their
support to do the research that we have done.
Obviously, gratitude to the patients and families that give us their
time, their samples, and their interest to support all the
correlative studies work and all the discovery work that we have done.
And I want to thank all the fellows I have trained over the years
together with the program.
Anna Sperafico is sitting here. She is our fellowship director, so if you want to
have a fellowship at Princess Margaret, call her, and
we will continue to build this network and
alliance of people that have trained with us and subsequently go home and train
others. It's been a very rewarding career for me to
train and work with so many people who have actually not
just become mentees,
but they have become great friends, and they have taught us a lot.
And the last slide is to really thank many of the people who have supported
my career.
I truly believe
nobody functions as a
single individual, and I think teamwork is the only way we can get things
done. I've been fortunate to be involved in many, many teams, and I've been
fortunate enough to work with basic
translational, clinical, and population scientists and
young investigators in my institution, and many abroad
that I have worked with that have become very good friends,
collaborators to build a research portfolio and
really spread the science and the medicine
across the globe. And I think at the end, all of us have the same
goal in mind, which is to improve the life and quality of life of our
patients. And I hope that we have achieved a little bit of
that through the work that we have done. Thank you for your attention.
I believe there are no questions, so you're now welcome to go
dancing. Thank you very much.